欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
同学们 这一章节我们来学习关于店铺流量增长的逻辑
如果你对店铺流量背后的增长逻辑都不清楚的话
那么你很难知道去操作哪些内容能够获得增长
也很难知道为什么我们店铺在增长
为什么我们店铺流量在暴跌
如果你理解了这个增长的逻辑
那么你就会非常的清晰
我哪个板块做的效果不好 从哪些维度还可以提升我们整个店铺的流量 所以这个店铺的流量增长逻辑一定要掌握 我们要把这个增长逻辑理顺了 才能够在正确的方向上用对的方法去运营店铺来实现我们循环稳步增长的目标
那么接下来 我们就来看一下 店铺流量增长逻辑 它到底是怎么样的 首先我们来看一下 这一整个PPT 底色的这一块 我们就相当于我们店铺的一个总的流量 店铺总流量 那么这些指标就代表着我们店铺里面所涉及到的增长的因子
这些指标就决定了我们店铺的整体的流量的大小和它的一个流量的天花板
另外一个就是这个是店铺层级的一个赛道的选择 如果你选的赛道越多或者是说你选的赛道比较合理 对于你们这个行业来说的话
那么他就能够给你这个店铺的整体的流量天花板能够往上拉升
比如说这边决定的天花板可能是A这条线 店铺从这里是0至起点
A是第一个天花板 也就是这些指标决定着你的店铺流量只能到A这个层级
那么B这个层级的话就是店铺层级 也就是你选的赛道
比如说你选定制赛道可能到B这个层级
从A到B这个层级
但是如果你选择了RTS跟定制赛道同时进行的话
可能你到达了 C 这个层级 店铺流量到 C 这个层级 如果你这个赛道全选了 连半托管都有了 那么你可能能往低这个层级发展 也就是说你的店铺的总的流量
是由你这边这些因子和你所选的赛道决定的 这个应该能理解吧
所以当我们这些赛道已经固定 比如说我已经定好了 我的店铺的赛道 这个是不变的
这赛道是不变的是吧 那么我这里是不是已经决定了 我就走这两个赛道
我通过提升我这边这些指标 因子的整体的效果来提升我整个店铺的总流量就能够达成了
比如说这些定的情况下 那么我A品类可能流量就是这么多
如果我品类就是这么多的话 我不增长 也就是说我品类可能就做10个品类
如果你把品类再往上拉的话 12个品类的话 那么可能也会对你这个店铺的总流量进行一个增长
那么我所做的国家 如果我的国家很少 比如说这里我增加了几个国家 是不是流量就上一个层级
C 也就是关键词覆盖量 我本来覆盖100个关键词 现在我覆盖1万个关键词
是不是也有可能给你的店铺的总流量能够带来一定的提升 你看 C 这板块 往上 流量是往上走的 再提升 比如说 1万个关键词里面
我有排名的可能是1000个 是不是有排名的词多了之后 是不是也会提升它的整体的流量
如果你这个关键词有排名的关键词越来越多 也就是从1000增长到了2000个有排名的关键词
那么它是不是又增加了你店铺的整体的总流量
再往上走 如果你这2000个关键词里面
它排名的位置之前可能排在第二到第三页为主的这些词
是不是它流量会相对少一点
但是呢 如果你的这2000个关键词从第二第三页排名
往前排到了第一页 排到了第一页 大量的词都在了第一页 那么是不是容易获得流量 更容易得到点击是不是能够给你的整个店铺增长流量
所以说一就是你的有排名的关键词 排名的位置提升了 那么你的整个店铺的总流量就在增长了
最后面就是关于场景流量 也就是你这些做的都挺好的 前面这些维度都挺好的
你店铺里面还有非常多的 真报品
真报品
你有真报品了之后 是不是能够获得更多的一个流量
场景流量 比如说榜单
榜单 加上一些猜你喜欢的推荐
加上一些新品场景 加上一些活动
你看这些流量都是免费的 而且它一增长起来的时候
是不是能够为你的整个店铺的一个流量层级
所以说 如果你想要提升你的整个店铺的总流量 一定要知道你店铺里面的总流量 是有哪些因子决定的 也就是这些因子决定的 ABCDEF都是你店铺流量增长的核心因子 你就非常清晰你要去增加哪些维度的数据 才能够持续的让你这个店铺流量增长
比如说现在是做几个品类 我增加了些品类 增加品类之后 是不是这些品类能够也会增加覆盖的关键词 是不是 这个在提升 这个也在提升 那么你这些品类可能对应的国家跟之前的国家不一样 那么是不是也增加了这些国家
这些国家增加了 是不是三条线在增加 那么你总的店铺的总流量有可能在增加吧 如果新发的这些品类有排名的关键词 总量也在增长
那么同时呢 它的排名的位置也在增长
是不是 就能够让你这店铺的总量再增长
另外就是你新增加的品类
它能够成为增报品之后
它能不能获得更多的这些流量呢
那么它如果获得更多流量
那么你的场景流量就会再增长
那么你的店铺的总流量也会再增长
所以呢 它是一连串的反应的
从源头开始 就是你选的品类开始 作为一个源头的入口
当你的品类在增加的时候 你所覆盖的国家可能增加 也可能不增加
但是它的池一定是在增加的 池增加的时候 是不是池的排名你做起来了 是不是有排名
同时它的流量是不是会增长 如果你在这新增的品类里面打造出爆品 是不是场景流量会增长
所以我们一定要记住店铺流量的增长逻辑 它是由这么多因子决定的
那么我们在日常操作的时候就会知道我们该怎么样去突破
同时呢 我们一定要记住这个店铺的一个增长模型
它是由这么多因子决定的 你的因子每个做得越好
那么都是在提升你整个店铺的总流量
理解吧 那么我们举个例子吧 比如说 A店铺 3 月份 4 月份 效果挺好的 是吧 突然间到了 5 月 6 月效果差了
那么我们怎么样去分析它效果变差了呢 你就要从这些维度去看 比如说品类 你有没有在减少
或者是说你的品类里面的这些关键词 有排名的关键词是不是在减少
他们排名的位置是不是在减少
那么他里面的这些产品是不是增报品变少了
是不是在下降
那么你看这一连串的反应
就是导致你5月跟6月效果变差的一个关键的影响指标
也就是我们要去从产品这个维度进行切入去分析的
因为那种产品能够衍生出国家关键词排名
还有排名的位置 还有场景流量 一切的源头都在于产品
这个就是开端 产品就是开端
所以我们只要捉住源头的问题 像洋葱一样一层一层的去拨开
那么我们就能够知道我们店铺为什么流量增长 为什么流量在暴跌
通过这个店铺流量增长的逻辑 你就能够非常快的找到问题
并针对性的去解决这些问题
那么这些都是关于操作层面的 那么关于店铺层题的又是怎么回事呢
比如说我们这些指标基本都不变 是吧 那么我们原始可能只做定制加RTS赛道的
近期国际上推出半托管这一个场景 那么如果我们店铺里面直接去增加这个品类的产品
是不是相当于我们店铺里面增加了一条流量的入口
那么流量的入口增加了 同时你发的这些半托管产品的效果也比较好 效果也比较好
那么你这个店铺的总流量得到增长的 也是会增长的 因为之前我们是靠定制跟RTS这两个赛道 这是第二个 这两个流量入口
现在增加了半托 这个半托相当于三条流量入口平台里面的流量 通过三条路径进入到你的店铺
是不是就容易拉升我们整个店铺的流量
它也是一样的逻辑
所以我们要从细节维度跟店铺层级的维度
店铺层级是一个非常大的维度
去提升我们店铺的整体的效果
其实说了那么多
我就是想让大家知道
店铺流量的增长与什么因子有关
以及我们可以去调整和优化哪些指标
如何去判断 如何去分析
这些方法我们前面都学过了
所以这个模型你只要记住了
那么对于你以后去判断去分析都是有非常清晰的思路的
只要你有思路
那么你就一定能够去不断的找新的方法去解决这个问题
但是很多时候因为我们没有思路
所以才不知道我们怎么样去做
即使你有方法但是你没有思路
你也不知道你这个方法是在解决你这个问题
所以说 思路非常重要 你不重视思路和不重视分析的一些维度 那么你的方法都是失效的 你只有有了思路 有了一些具体的判断指标 那么你的方法才能够更有针对性 才能够更快的起作用 这个增长逻辑大家一定要重视起来 那么这节课 我们就先讲到这里 下节课 我们再见